round 2 of the US and US women's Chess  Championship here in st. Louis the top  players in the country picked up from  the first round and excitement with even  more fire blazing chess that ended in  many dramatic victories Wesley so in  version of Kobe and each one they're  second in a row to stay atop the  leaderboard while Fabiano karana  and Ray Robson had crushing wins that  allowed them to keep pace on the ladies  side 2016 champion nasi by Kizzy and  last year's champ Sabina Pfizer managed  to draw to topsy-turvy affairs while  Maggie Fang arena crush and henna  sitarski all one to conclude one of the  bloodiest days in championship history  the players are already swinging for the  fences as their fighting spirit is on  full display round three action starts  right now